good morning mr. Prescott how are you
doing I'm getting a bit nervous about
the way things ago okay we're here to
put when every boat we can get I'm a
it's a chore to label people do you
think it would be good if Ed Miliband
without on the stump in the way that you
are I mean seeing the rest of it but
it's doing that at the moment incomin
are you're gonna bit of a section here
anticipating my life isn't it a bit from
you or helpers but they're quite robust
on the side think that you've got enough
stomach for this fight I've been always
there we go I'm gonna let you inspect
yourself as you can see someone from the
yes campaign going up straight in John
Prescott face there is an asaba the MP
is hoping to introduce
in the email I feel I got the airport
today and my wife told me to bring up up
with the proper scuffle and they took it
off me and said you can't take that you
can pay 40 pound on it Matthew Smith
have we got border controls already
beginning better together he's
absolutely right when I got on one of my
campaign buses they tell me that the
Scottish football team's coach is that
right well I got a revolutionary thought
for you praxic England and Scotland to
get that out one team we couldn't last
beat the Germans who knows what we're
here to celebrate is they debate that
was taking place here a democratic
debate for devolution in the United
Kingdom which the Labour Party has
always supported and brought about